[Music]
in this video
we're going to discuss how to view use
and track usage of promotional credits
such as startup credits and your google
cloud billing account
let's get started to view your
promotional credits
start in the cloud console use the
left-hand navigation to head to the
billing console
choose the billing account for which
you'd like to view your promotional
credits
then locate the credits pane in the
bottom right hand
corner click through to credit details
to see a list of your credits
including the credit's original value
remaining value
start date and end date if the credits
pane does not appear on the account
overview page
it means that the account does not have
any credits
note it may take up to 20 minutes after
redeeming credits to see them in the
console
to use credits make sure your google
cloud projects are linked to the billing
account which has the credits applied
note that promotional credits apply to
future use of google cloud platform
products
and cannot be applied retroactively so
you are responsible for any amount
accrued prior to the credits being
redeemed
credits are valid for the given time
frame after redemption date which is
viewable in the credit details you saw
earlier
or when the credits are fully depleted
whichever comes first
after you've used your credits you can
track their usage at a high level on the
cost
breakdown tab or you can dig a little
deeper and analyze them
on the reports tab if you use the cloud
billing export to bigquery
you can analyze your credit usage by
unnesting the credits field
an example query is linked in the video
description
head over to the documentation to check
out more details
you